GOALS AGAINST AVERAGE AND SAVE
STARTING FOR THE THEIR LAST
SIX.
THEY HAD FOUR SHOTS ON
GOAL.
POPS PASS.
DEFLECTED BY KYLE OFF?
>> HE MADE THES THERE FROM ONE
MEN I SINGLE SEASON
RECORD.
CHECK BY FOX.
TO ADAM LOWRY.YEAH, SCHMITT HUR
HAND OR WRIST.
HAD TO STAY OUT THERE.
MEANWHILE, THE JETS.
PASS DEFLECTED OFF THE STICK
OFOF
SECOND
AND SCORE!E.
SAM, YESTERDAY IN PRACTICE RIGHT
AFTER PRACTICE
WIDE.
BROUGHT OUT BYES OFF.
HE HAD ONE MORE GEAR.
MILLER DID NOT HAVE GOOD
POSITIONING
GAMES.
HE CAME BACK FROM AN INJURY.
>> HE MISSED A BUNCH OF SAVES
HERE IS DUBOIS AGAIN.CHANCE.
THE OPPORTUNITIES WINNIPEG IS
GETTING, THEY'RE ALL OF THE
HIGHEST
GOALS AGAINST AVERAGE AND SAVE
PERCENTAGE.
LOGAN STANLEY BACK IS THERE.
CHYTIL.
TRYING TO PLAY IT.
BOY OH, BOY.
IF YOU ARE WATCHING, WE
THE NET CHANCES.
>> YEAH. PLAY IS OVER.
HAD IT T
ANOTHER ONE MISSES.
WIDE OPEN ON THAT ONE.
P
POINTS.
THROUGHOUT THE SEASON.
IT'S 91
HE SCORES!
WHOA!
THE BLOCKS.
HE WENT FROM B IT.
>> Sam: ANDREW COPP PICKS UP AN
SEASON.
>> Sam: SPEAKING OF LONG ISLA
DEFLECTIONS ANDSTEAD OF JUST FI